so I always thought this was gonna be
like the end of the game I don't know I
could only lasted about two hours but I
didn't realize back then their
PlayStation 4 games were unlike the
PlayStation 3 ones about 17 hours
minimum so yeah I thought like oh he's
got the lard now he's gonna smash his
face and you can see their scarecrows
clearly like damage still from his
encounter with Killer Croc in Arkham
Asylum and it's it's great how the
stakes are raised yeah I don't know why
throws the lad down on the ground there
if you should have like incapacitated
him in some way because he's clearly
gonna sneak off but yeah oh what a
surprise he just stares smoke out the
room when you were on your phone that's
sort of a metaphor for kids today they
miss everything that's going on because
they're standing about on their phone
talking to some girl like Batman was so
we're all a bit like Batman in a way
when you think about it yeah this bits a
bit boring because you literally just a
war hit walking about the room playing
sort of the interactive digital version
of operation I don't know if you ever
played that game but you basically got a
move as slowly as possible and yeah
metal conductors and pick stuff out of
the hole without setting the trap off in
that that's pretty much what this
section of the game is so not exactly
the most fun thing to do when you're
playing as Batman I remember this pretty
much just yeah if you fail on this as
well you try to do the whole thing again
it sort of slows down there the pacing a
bit but you know it does feel a lot more
tense as it starts to ramp up you see
the explosions about you and you realize
that if Batman does go through with it
then it's gonna like kill himself
and there's scarecrows
masks they're on the floor just lying
about I don't know why the hell that's
there you must adjust you know he was
wearing it just to bring back the good
old days it is quite strange that
because last time we seen that it was on
top of a bridge on Arkham City so he's
went up there he's got that down he's
carried it around in his pocket and he's
just been walking around with it he's
been walking around with two masks a bit
like Batman I don't know if you ever
seen like sometimes in stuff a on mask
Batman and he's got a he's got a mask
underneath it like a like a weirdo that
was always a great bit of the game when
the Joker shows back up um obviously
it's you know it's widely known now that
the Joker's a massive part of Arkham
Knight and I always kind of wondered if
they were going to bring them back even
though they killed him in the last one
and to be honest the way that they do in
this game which is where you're
constantly hallucinating that he's there
and because you Batman knows the Joker
so intimately he's able to you know
accurately give the responses that the
Joker would it just adds such a depth to
the villain and actually prefer that em
over and being a physical presence in
this game right I think it works a lot
better just him constantly be in there
the banner that he provides is also like
really engrossing and it's great how
Batman's biggest fear is that he's one
day gonna turn into the Joker and you
know he's in his head and you can sort
of see things from his side and it makes
Batman a lot more relatable you've got
in this scene here Commissioner Gordon's
approaching the new Batcave which is
located at Panetta studios I'm not a big
fan of the the Panetta Studios thing I
think it would have been better if you
went to to Gotham oh sorry to Wayne
Manor got the Gray Ghost there famously
that emerging a Batman animated series
episode in which Adam West appears to do
the voice of the Gray Ghost
and it basically centers around this
murderer
who's committing the crimes that once
happened in the gray ghost TV show so
Batman enlists the help of the Gray
Ghost Adam West and they sort of work
together to take down this criminal and
it's just a really good like callback to
the 1966 show and it's one of me
favorites you know and we've got Gordon
here sort of exploring all this it's
great that Batman sort of brought them
into the ground level and because the
threats gotten so big and I remember
seeing this for the first time and kind
of not known exactly what was going on
and but obviously you can see on these
characters like they're they are getting
very similar looks wise to the Joker
like this could easily be a cosplay you
know they're masters who walk around
comic-con dressed as the Joker yeah so
there's there's the one there's another
he's probably the the closest but he
also probably has the best bit in the
game I think so it's great seeing all
these characters sort of different takes
on the joke they're almost M which you
know every ten years when we get a
rebooted universe we get a different
take on the Joker and I don't see some
of these some of these could fit right
in like the female one's really good
Johnny charisma is really good the rest
like I you know he's all right the old
guy he's really good this lad have some
great bit oh and it's good how Batman
just sneaks up behind them like all
right I wouldn't see Annabelle last
night and a quite a lot of jump scares
are from people just walking in the room
gun hey what you up to what you doing
this is time back in with Arkham City
and it's sort of picking up the loose
ends that were left there and they you
know I didn't see it the first time but
they heavily hint
spoiler alert that Batman's slowly
succumbing to this disease as well
because you've got the the cell there
that hasn't got anyone
I mean Batman heavily insinuates during
this section that you know there's one
person oh I wonder who that one could be
and it's very pointed out but I never
picked up on it like look he's in he's
in the cell so did you get that you know
there's a comment section on this video
no one ever uses it so thanks for that
but you can make the difference now and
write down did you know that spoiler and
another great aspect of this game is how
close they get into things and then they
can zoom out but there's so much detail
on and everything you can
this is definitely the best looking
Joker in a game that we've ever seen and
it's just absolutely breathtaking how
good this is and the fact that they
managed to keep it a secret that Mark
Hamill was in the game and was
absolutely amazing so Mark Hamill really
like didn't mention anyway and I think
even in the lead-up to this Mark Hamill
said that you would never ever play the
Joker again unless they did The Killing
Joke which of course they did end up
doing the animated series version of
yeah wasn't amazing was it like that
that first hour Barbara Gordon was
terrible but anyway they kept all the
secret that he was in the game I mean
just to have him come back was like a
massive massive fan moment for me like
Pryor fanboy doubt there and Mark Hamill
obviously famously played Luke Skywalker
and it's good that his career sort of
getting a revival and he's appeared in
the flash a couple of times and
obviously Star Wars is massive now honey
it's good that little lads finally get
in the middle you know the respect that
he deserves because he's such a good
voice actor if you ever get a chance to
check out x2 on the PlayStation 2 with
the Wolverine the actually voices
Wolverine through that entire game and
his voice is completely unrecognizable I
mean so you just give that a quick
little YouTube and it's crazy how much
it's over now dynamics he has within his
voice and how he's able to perform and
this is sort of a great callback to The
Killing Joke
as mentioned before you've got Barbara
Gordon there and she's just she's just
sitting chilling at home it's not quite
how it happened in the original story
because Commissioner Gordon was there
with her the Joker then just comes in
shoots he makes a joke about how she's
broke the coffee table
she's a hardcover edition but their
spines a little broken that's that's
great I don't know how he knew that he
broke a spine from shooting her but you
know it's gray and originally in The
Killing Joke the Joker actually
undresses Barbara Gordon and it's very
heavily insinuated that he molested err
or stuff like that and basically it's
all sort of in the vein of trying to
turn Commissioner Gordon insane
and so when he when the Joker kidnaps
Commissioner Gordon he takes him on a
funhouse ride that then
you know it's sort of it's very horrific
and it displays all of the photos of
Barbara in her own dress and not very
nice at all and I love the way that this
game constantly tank changes the
environment around you it's just so
seamless and I'd never ever seen
anything in a game like this before so
the way that just everything merges
together it's it's absolutely brilliant
and it's definitely just it keeps up the
illusion that you loosen a ting whereas
you don't have lune loading screens and
it's just so well done and you've also
got the Oracle symbol there hanging up
that mask sort of is often used by
Oracle as a motif and sort of a
signature you've got the Shakespeare bus
there as well from the 1966 Batman
series that is a big massive part of the
show it's what Batman and Robin used to
open the Batcave up so it's nice to just
see in the background there um yeah and
just lovely little touch
and this is saw a Batman painting oh
yeah by the way you door she was Emeril
in all this [ __ ] that I had and it's a
bit of a shame that Barbara Gordon you
know she was crippled by the Joker and
when they did the new 52 they rebooted
the universe so that she was paralyzed
for some point but she eventually got
these other legs back which don't want
to sound like you know actually prefer
the character when she was paralyzed
because it sort of was empowering for
for disabled people to to really see
that you know whilst she is paralyzed
that she's not helpless there's still
things that she can do in the world she
still massively assists Batman she to me
she's she was Batman's greatest ally the
Intel that she provides you know she's
there always the voice in his ears she's
always really helping him and that was
kind of taken away with the new 52
reboot you know it's it's there's pros
and cons to it because the new 52 Batman
yes Batgirl is she's she's great but
yeah losing Oracle I'm kind of like kind
of which Oracle was still around because
great character gave a great message for
disabled people much in the same way
that daredevil does as well you know
that disabled people aren't left out
because of the disability with Oracle
you know they're they're as much a
helping hand
as the Allies who are out there in the
field
unfortunately this part of the game sort
of really slows the pacing down so I've
basically just been driving along I've
had a disarm a bomb by protecting it
from getting shot upon by tanks you know
the boring bits and then you get a
little itch and you've got a disarm
you've got a lower the braid
well then in doing so Riddler pops up
and you guide gosub Riddler from gettin
my cat what was some crap minutes
basically there's too many roadblocks at
this part of the game that you know you
just want to just get on with it I know
a lot of people kind of dislike the fear
multi takedowns to be honest that I
quite like it the way that adds a bit of
strategy into building them up and
chaining all your combos together and
yeah it's a bit gamey but you know it's
not a horrendous there's a lot worse
thing in this game especially the 410
dang things but I mean like those two
ways that I've taken down the group
there where one was I did the the Bill
of the takedown and used that to
basically dismantle all my files the
other one was I just threw a smoke bomb
down and used that just you know just
pull a guy in and be the [ __ ] out of
them and so there is sort of a hit and
miss thing there with them likewise I
can see why people do dislike them I
think it's a nice thing and there's a
lot of strategic moments like that in
games now like if you play Splinter Cell
you can build up combo takedowns like
that if you if you have a stealth one
and it just speeds up the gameplay
really and I think it makes you feel a
lot more like Batman like you rushes in
has the element of surprise and again
it's another thing that Zack Snyder
captured perfectly in Batman V Superman
I haven't really got massive beef with
it could be honest I once read a ledge
talking a lot of crap we've got em the
two blimps there and it's it's great how
throughout the game they sort of moved
towards the island there where they
eventually get harpooned in
there they play a huge aspect in the
Gotham skyline and I think it's sort of
inspired by the Watchmen comic book if
you read that there's there's a lot of
blimps inand that kind of plays into the
sort of art decor style that Gotham City
as a whole has um and it's just nice to
see them in the skyline if you ever
watched the first episode of the Batman
animated series that's how it starts off
it's got the blimps floating along man
back comes flies in front of them and
then I think Batman does and it's just
it's just a really good good thing to
see them in the skyline you can also see
in the skyline there Wayne Manor and
I've just passed me riddle there and
there's a buddy Joker sitting on the
balcony and so thanks very much for
checking out my video really appreciate
it I'm gonna be doing a playthrough like
this every week where I sort of played
through the game show you the highlights
and then from there sort of talk more in
depth about what inspired the creators
if there were any graphic novels like
that or what it's sort of been
replicated in the films and so yeah
thanks a lot for checking us out like my
channel if you want and subscribe to it
as well please yeah otherwise I'll knock
you out and I'll see you next time
thanks a lot bye